what kind of bag would it take to get
you guys to come back together to do
like a one-off bag a super bag it's got
it because I already make a bag
look at your jewelry I'm like I just
want to go get some New Jersey too but
yo I feel like maybe in like five years
if you guys did like a reunion tour it'd
be kind of like it'd be kind of crazy
not me tell you I'm not opposed to it we
just need that baggie for me because
it's not not like anything ever happened
to where you guys are like yeah
it'd have to be a good business movie
yeah exactly exactly I respect that what
about to do an album yeah same
let's just get a bag man right in that
bag here would your bag have to be
bigger than everybody else's
it would make sense
was that kind of like a big reason like
why what was the nah because
um me and Phoenix was uh with everything
was split 50 50 so and then the the
other homies was only on like two three
songs so right it was really like you in
Phoenix right yeah I always wonder like
when I think it was just like everybody
wanted to do their own for real